michel leblanc est président et chef de
la direction de la chambre de commerce
du montréal métropolitain michel leblanc
bonsoir bonsoir
est ce que vous êtes d'accord vous avec
ce nouveau report écoutez la question
n'a jamais été est ce qu on est d'accord
ou pas les raisons sont sanitaires et
mieux les affaires ne conteste pas les
évaluations qui sont faits pour des
raisons sanitaires
en même temps faut bien réaliser à quel
point ça rajoute encore ou quoi que
portent sur leurs épaules les commerces
à une résignation a évidemment on va
faire avec
et la réalité c'est qu'il y avait déjà
une semaine de décalage en début de
semaine ont annoncé une semaine
additionnelle et l'on vient d'annoncer
une aube semaines additionnelles
rappelons nous que pour les commerçants
depuis le début de la crise
ils ont fermé dans la majorité des cas
ils n'ont pas de revenus et donc plus il
ya une énorme incertitude d'abord est-ce
que je tiens coup probablement qui
change ici je vais me rendre
deuxièmement est-ce que je vais avoir
mes employés on l'a vu avec la
prestation canadienne d'urgence l'inde
qui fournit aux étudiants ça viendra
compliquer leur rappelle dans ces
emplois qui sont pas toujours des
emplois 20 heures ou plus de leurs mais
plutôt un bond de 20 dollars et
troisièmement c'est ce que me criant
voit un plat il quand on déconne comme
ça ben déjà des clients de la région
montréal près 30 et peut-être tentés
d'aller faire une virée à savoir qu'une
virée au reader ou dans nord est et à
l'est dans les magasins qui sont ouverts
évidemment c'est pas la même expérience
sur le vieux la télé mais pour un
commerçant ça me rajoute encore une
pression est ce que vous craignez kyi et
d'autres situations comme celle d'al
d'eau qui aujourd'hui se placer sous la
protection des tribunaux
écoutez si aldo s'offre imaginons la
situation pour un tous les autres
évidemment il ya une réalité aussi qui
était et je connais pas le cas dans le
dos mais dans beaucoup d'entreprises
il y avait déjà des défis majeurs liés
aux commerçants il y avait un
affaiblissement de la situation sur
plusieurs affaires commerciales donc
dans les faits on n'arrivait pas avec
des commerces qui ont des réserves de
liquidités en réserve
au début de cette pandémie alors assuré
marc devant nous il y aussi situation
difficile
est-ce que ça va se produire à grande
échelle
j'ai l'impression que les premières
semaines vont être déterminante si les
clients sont là et si la reprise melon
se passe
eh bien ça devrait aller pour beaucoup
de commerces la ville de montréal dès
aujourd'hui s'attendre une proportion de
40 à 50% de locaux vacants sur certaines
artères et il ya toujours des solutions
qui sont amenés à il ya eu toute une
étude une évaluation qui était fait une
consultation avant la crise où on est
bon il ya déjà un problème de locaux
vacants est ce qu'on devrait pas avoir
une taxe ou une redevance aux
propriétaires de locaux vacants
vous en pensez-quoi excès en les
contrant demeure tenté on voit être
contre l'idée de renforcer nos artères
commerciales c'est de l'année de
l'achalandage c'est surtout pas de
mettre des taxes punitives sur des
propriétaires qui ont vu leurs
locataires fermés parfois un 2ème
locataire et qui voit bien que la
transformation du commerce du commerce
de détail les a faits je ne pense pas
que c'est d'arriver avec un bâton et je
pense que la mairesse qui est dit
aujourd'hui que pour l'instant et
j'espère et c'est pour longtemps
elle ne veut pas taxer davantage je ne
pense pas que c'est la bonne solution du
tout a dit valérie plantes travailler
sur un plan de relance estivale
comment vous voyez l'été 2020 qui est si
formidable dans une ville comme montréal
comment vous voyez ça dans les prochains
mois ben écoute et faut regarder en
europe pour essayer de voir ce qui peut
arriver à montréal on voit en europe
le décompte final d'un milieu
progressivement mais quand même assez
rapidement sur l'espace d'un mois à de
la réouverture du restaurant à des
petits groupes peuvent se réunir on est
quand même en mai ou début mai je parle
qu'on risque de permettre un montréal où
on pourra goûter à l'été mais on pourra
pas fêter nécessairement à plusieurs et
peut-être qu'il faudrait réfléchir sur
comment on fait comme montréal à
montréal à l'automne je pense qu'on peut
qualifier l'été mais on voit ce thème si
un automne qui ressemble peut-être panoz
était pire univers si on le pouvait qui
fait trop aussi mais est ce qu'on
faisait quand même de plaine fille
michel leblanc est ce que vous êtes
capable de planifier comme chambre de
commerce la paix vous parler à tous les
gens d'affaires
est ce qu'on est capable de s'imaginer
compte tenu qu'on ne sait pas et qu'on
repose c'est qu'on reporte puis qu'on
attend aussi les plantes phase 2 et
france 3 et vous saviez comment combien
de gens à montréal qui sont dans
l'événementiel dans divertissement dans
l'accueil de tourisme pense à des clans
pense à des façons dans durant l'été
durant l'automne regarde ce qu'on va
pouvoir permettre à partir de l'europe à
partir toujours de ce qui se passe
là-bas faut se rappeler qu'ils ont un
mot à six semaines deux heures en avance
sur nous alors je vous dis à montréal il
ya plein de noms qui réfléchissent
évidemment ça va prendre des sous on va
se retourner vers les gouvernements en
grande partie il ya des commanditaires
privés qui vont être là une société
d'état comme hydro québec continue de
vente d'électricité
alors il va falloir investir mais je
pense qu'il présentement arrivent avec
des bonnes idées pour relancer
est ce que la reprise va s'accompagner
d'un véritable mouvement d'achat local
et est ce que vous allez valoriser ça
écoutez on veut valoriser c'est
intéressant on avait un événement avant
clients avec jean-marc léger ou ans posé
la question combien les québécois sont
prêtes à payer pour acheter le cas les
gens mal digérées avec des chiffres
ils nous disent les québécois sont prêts
à payer entre 3 et 8 % de plus pour que
ce soit en local alors le message à tout
le monde qui veut vendre de calmants
c'est qu' il faudrait être concurrentiel
il s'appelle souci par des systèmes de
distribution il faut que ce soit aussi 5
de commander et d'obtenir le calme en
que quand on voit sur les grandes à
former un grand défi mais assurément
qu'on va l'encourager on voit là cuillé
et on voit le communiqué si on le peut à
fond c'est dans l'intérêt de tout le
monde
michel leblanc merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup à tout le monde